the main message of my work over the
past decade or more has been a fairly
basic message and that's that every
single human being is creative but then
as with anything one has to put
statistical parameters around what that
means and what I found is that in the
United States and around the world
our society is really dividing into
people who are principally paid to use
their creativity at work and those who
may be quite creative but are there
principally had to use their physical
labor or they're involved in low-skilled
service work in in any event there are
about 40 million Americans who are
privileged to be members of what I call
the creative class there are people in
science and technology there are people
who are entrepreneurs who work in
research and development they're
architects they're designers they work
in arts and culture the entertainment
and media and then the kind of classic
knowledge-based professionals that that
great management thinkers like Peter
Drucker taught us about people in
business and management and healthcare
and law and education right now in the
United States it's about 35% of the
workforce but what's what's interesting
is through the terrible economic crisis
we've had while rates of unemployment
for manufacturing workers when over 15%
in some cases over 20% and for people
who do low-skilled service work like
food preparation or personal care that
kind of work went well over 10% the rate
of unemployment amongst the creative
class never went higher than 5% and you
know we're on track to generate another
7 million of these jobs over the course
of the next decade and and one thing
that's really interesting when I first
look at the creative class in the
original version of the book in 2002 in
the most advanced regions of the
countries places like San Francisco or
the Silicon Valley or Boulder Colorado
or Austin Texas or Seattle or Boston
raleigh-durham Washington DC there might
have been 35 or 40% now in some of these
regions almost 50% of the workforce
we're sitting in Manhattan today and in
New York County which is Manhattan it's
nearly half of the workforce is already
in this creative class and we have been
able to look around the world we added a
whole new chapter on that in this book
you know in some countries like
Singapore or in Sweden or in Norway or
in Denmark the Netherlands already more
than 45 to 50
percent of the workforce is doing this
kind of creative class work so in in my
view it's it's the growth force of our
time and the real challenge ahead of us
is how do we get more and more people
involved in creative class work using
their minds using their creativity
because it will afford them a better
salary it will improve productivity and
it'll hopefully begin to address the
terrible inequality we face in our
country